protestas en tel aviv en rechazo a las
renovadas restricciones israel ha vuelto
a imponer la obligatoriedad de las
máscaras en interiores y una vez más
exige su llamado pase verde para todos
los lugares con más de 100 personas ya
que la variante delta más contagiosa
está impulsando un aumento de caso casi
al 60% de la población está
completamente vacunado pero
aproximadamente un millón de israelíes
todavía se niegan a recibir la inyección
el pueblo de israel y el pueblo del
mundo tienen su soberanía y ellos son
los que deciden si quieren recibir algún
tratamiento médico en su cuerpo sabemos
que en todas partes la gente está
marchando estamos haciendo lo mismo
estamos unidos gritando la libertad los
manifestantes suizos tomaron las calles
en guinea y lucerna repudiando las
restricciones del país y el certificado
job y escenas similares se vieron en la
vecina italia en milán cientos de
personas también marcharon contra el
pase verde de ese país un documento que
muestra prueba de vacunación resultado
negativo de tesco bit o recuperación de
un contagio reciente y a partir del 6 de
agosto se requerirá para ingresar
la mayoría de los lugares incluidos los
cines y el interior de los restaurantes
esto en medio de la rápida propagación
de la variante delta que ahora
representa casi el 95% de los casos en
italia según el instituto nacional de
salud del país
el pase verde no es más que una
herramienta de chantaje para intentar
aumentar el número de personas obligadas
a vacunar sin embargo las protestas
fueron disueltas sensible más de 1000
policías fueron enviados a la ciudad más
grande de australia para evitar
manifestaciones después de que miles se
manifestaran contra el cierre de esa
localidad la semana pasada